but so this is just like the way the men
are gonna see this is like it's like
you're almost becoming it entitled and
I'm not trying to offend you it's just
like because to me I'm like 2500 a month
Andy said she could do it on like 200 a
month no that's that's fine but in in
reality she doesn't have a baby with an
NBA player right so what also is it what
let me finish though so what's why it's
entitled it's law it this isn't like my
personal opinion and I've learned
actually a lot about the law in
Charlotte for child support
um my mom got a hundred dollars for me
and uh my brother but again it goes off
based on your income and what the child
would be accustomed to so that's where
all of the the opinions don't [ __ ]
matter because if my son is getting
picked up in a Lamborghini
it's like he has to be in a equivalent
like the judge doesn't want there to be
too big of a gap and that is law so
people can be upset and feel how they
want but take it up with your judicial
system like this is what it is yeah